my name is Billy Collins I was born on
West 30th Street I should point out
there's a difference between the me that
was autobiographically shaped and the
persona that says my poems my persona
has had New York has had no influence on
my persona
well it's influenced me I suppose just
that and I grew up in a fairly
cosmopolitan and crazy environment so I
guess I'm not too easily impressed by
eccentricity for one thing since if you
walk down one block in Manhattan you see
you know it's like person obviously the
parents probably my father for his sense
of humor he was a joker he had a lot of
formal jokes but he also had zingers you
know these one-liners that were he had
enough zinger for every occasion and he
was a very it was a practical joker as
well I we don't have time to go into his
practical jokes perhaps but suffice it
to say that the kind of pranks he pulled
on office workers he worked on Wall
Street would today be would qualify as
psychological harassment in those days
the practical joke still was I think
unprosecuted all my mother for her
basically for I mean more relevantly for
interest in poetry she was both my
parents were born in 1901 and they lived
well into their 90's both of them and
she was raised born and raised on a
little farm in
Ontario Canada which is my big claim to
ethnicity I'm half Canadian I guess and
but as a child she memorized lots of
poetry and though that was the thing to
do in those days memorization was not
thought of as old hat or a little red
schoolhouse so as an adult she was a
storehouse of poetry and could produce
lines of poetry for just as my father
had zingers for every occasion she would
have a few lines of poetry for every
every every occasion
so poetry was in the air it was in the
it was in the house and I was influenced
by teachers of course but one thing
about tea about being influenced by
teachers I can remember in terms of my
poetry writing a number of teachers who
who encouraged me to keep writing and
seem like innocent thing to do at the
time and but the teachers I really
remember vividly were the two or three
teachers who were very discouraging to
me and very dismissive of my poetry and
we're quick to tell me that it was
nothing but a bunch of teenage hormonal
overdrive or overspill and they might
have been right in an aesthetic literary
critical sense but they really inspired
me to keep writing to prove them wrong
and I think I mean I know I have a much
keener appetite for revenge than I do
for approval so the teachers that have
proved to me I approval never meant that
much to me I think I got so much for my
mother I didn't need outside approval
but if you discouraged me that would get
me going and when I got a phone call
from the librarian of Congress in 2001
telling me I was poet laureate of the
United States I thought of those
teachers and who discouraged me and that
added a little bit of sugar
to the experience probably another juice
no she's the mother of us all I mean
those are the you know I mean writing
poetry or painting or dancing or playing
the trumpet all of these activities that
we consider art for lack of a better
name are really I think just extensions
of natural childhood activities a
childhood desires that are enacted I
mean as children we are painters dancers
just give a kid a flute and he'll start
playing it and end writers I mean all
children love rhyme
I think poets are artists who just are
just people who somehow didn't allow
that natural ability in childhood to be
killed off by bad teaching the
self-consciousness of adolescence and a
lot goes down the drains because of that